so I'd like to introduce our presenter
today we have Joe bowler dr. Joe bowler
is a profession a professor of
mathematical mathematics education at
Stanford University and the co-founder
of YouTube she's an analyst for Pizza
testing in the OECD an author of the
first MOOC on mathematics teaching and
learning
former rules have concluded being the
Marie Curie professor of mathematics
education for Europe a mathematics
teacher in London comprehensive schools
and a researcher at King's College in
London now I'd like to turn it over to
Jill good morning everybody
it's really great to be talking with you
all this morning I know we have people
from across the education sector and
from many different countries
so welcome whether you're here within
the United States or in a different
country and it's always great to have
the international participation so I'm
going to be sharing some research today
salad which may be new to you and some
of which is probably less so and we're
going to watch some videos together also
and I'll just jumped straight in by
telling you that I was in Norway
yesterday seems amazing but it was a
really really interesting event I
thought you'd like to hear a little bit
about it in Norway they present a Matt
Hossack prize it's called the Apple
Prize for mathematics and it was won by
a magazine called Eve's Maya and what's
really nice is they also have a teacher
prize that goes along with it and so I
thought you'd like to some of my photos
from Norway the first one I this is the
Eve Meier being presented with the prize
by the king of Norway
that was pretty exciting and this and I
just thought you'd like their picture
this is where the King lives and those
banners are actually for the prize the
mathematics price which there is a whole
series of events week-long in Norway
around this mathematics prize so it's
pretty exciting great as I highlight max
in that way this is the teacher Hannah
and Mohammed Abdullah and who won the
teacher prize
and without any of us knowing this what
was amazing was when she was presenting
to everybody she was showing all the
things from YouTube that she uses in her
teaching and very strongly talking about
how she communicates the students that
there's no such thing as a math person
and that anybody can learn math so that
was really great to see that and see
YouTube getting outdoor and wide and
this picture I thought you'd like to see
is from the Sand Creek we went to a very
fancy banquet the night before last and
lots of mathematicians were there from
Earth from international group of very
important mathematicians that's picture
of me with the award and then one of my
favorite moments of the evening was the
chat with the Minister of Education for
Norway here he is with myself and Kathy
Williams from you cubed wearing his
national costume so loves he said to me
do you think your American colleagues
will think out from Lord of the Rings so
I don't know I don't know what your
answer to that is but anyway that was a
great conversation about 21st century
mathematics in Norway so starting some
of the things I want to share with you
today I am working more closely these
days really at the intersection of
athletics and learning about my products
and also neuroscience and we're doing
that
partly couldn't sell some really
important myths that are out there about
maps and in display those most refined
it changes people to relationships with
maps people's family so it be no
surprise to anyone that I'm going to
start with this idea that we know now
that nobody's born with a math brain and
nobody's born out on and in fact
incredible research on brain science
brain plasticity showing that everybody
spraying can grow and change to learn
any mathematics and we need to get rid
of the idea to Stan students are born
with a mouse brain and some are not so
the next slide was animated but it's not
going to show up as an animation in red
X unfortunately but I would not this one
so the brain we know is our most context
organ it's made of over a hundred
billion neurons and several thousand
connections between them and how do we
be kept well and mastering how does it
this is the slide that's no longer M&A
animated but what it would have shown
you is that when you learn something to
use is one of three things that happen
one is a new brain pathway conform
another thing that can happen is a
current brain property you already have
become strengthened and then a third
possibility is that brain pathways that
you have connect with each other so when
we think about students having a
mathematics brain this is how you get
one from learning new ideas that form
pathways in the brain and then stay with
you for you to use in your brain from
that point onwards and that seems pretty
important for students to know that
that's how brain brains form and learn
new mathematics and new mathematics
pathways and that's really what's meant
by growing your brain some of you will
know that we've been sending out
messages that mistakes grow your brain
and it takes a really good for your
brains and that's what really that's
that brain growth really means it's
sometimes it's forming pathways
sometimes it's strengthening and
pathways and making connections between
them so I'm really interesting new
research coming out opening on brain
connections and so people wonder what
makes people more intelligent and know
more things and more accomplished and
they really try to figure out what is it
about their brains some people think you
have to have got a larger brain it's not
that at all and in fact what makes
people more conversational knowledgeable
is a stronger set of connections between
parts of the brain as it says here the
dynamic interplay of neural networks
that operate in concert and draw from
different parts of the brain at once so
today I'm going to talk to you about how
encourage those brain connections there
was a really interesting article that
recently came out of the National
Geographic and it was called what makes
a genius so trying to figure out if we
call certain people in the world a
genius who have just done amazing things
so they took that Einstein and
Michelangelo what makes them different
in their brains and actually have
Einstein's brain in a museum chopped up
and people stare at it all the time
there's no difference in size of brain
but what they're doing now
bringing in people who are super
accomplished and and having scans for
their brains that look at what's going
on inside their brains and they find as
it says here that there's quite a
notable difference between those that
they think of the genius that there is
more communication going on between the
different hemispheres those people are
more flexible in their thought processes
and more contributions are coming from
different parts of the brain so clearly
this is what we want to developing this
or communication between parts of the
brain or connections and mathematics can
play a really important role in that so
lots and lots of evidence that people
may be born with differences in their
brains but those differences are really
eclipsed by the millions of
opportunities to grow and change brains
and all students have the potential to
learn any level of mathematics with the
right teaching so I want to have us now
look into something we did at Stanford
recently and that is we brought 81
students onto campus and we gave them
these different messages about brain
science we told them that mistakes are
really important and struggle is really
important we told them that speed is not
important
and then we taught mathematics
differently is an open creative subject
that really backs up those messages we
gave them and the new online class that
I have coming out in the summer is
actually based around the videos that we
took at camp
everything's filmed by filmmaker and
we're going to watch some of that today
decided isn't mush together we've lost
some of it so we will send this out to
you after the webinar but we are what
would happen if we changed all of these
things we stopped kids thinking that
your maths personal you're not and we
replace the lamb because from speed and
procedures with wanton depth and
creativity and we got rid of the idea
that was one way and instead celebrated
the multiple different ideas students
have in different ways different ways of
visualizing and and what's lost at the
bottom is really moving away from works
the individual to being a collaborative
process so and this graph shows you the
Cree
schools that the 81 students we brought
to campus it was a test of taken in
their district on algebra and what you
may be able to see there is 81 bars that
represent the 81 students and you can
probably tell the return a wide range of
achievement amounts to students we had
very high achieving students we have
students who scored zero on the pretest
we put them into four classes they were
all mixed we didn't have any tracking or
grouping and then we taught them open
creative mathematics for 18 lessons they
were with us in the mornings rate for
the lessons math lessons I was a teacher
Cathy and others and regular classroom
teachers also here for classes and then
in the afternoon they were able to sort
of run around campbellton my undergrads
so they had this day's experience and at
the end of the 18 lessons we gave them
the same district algebra test that
they've taken in their district and even
though we didn't focus on that test at
all the schools of the students you can
see it massively went up by an average
of 50 percent per student which is a
huge amount of an educational
intervention not all students as you can
see increased but the increases you're
probably noticed come from across the
achievement spectrum high achievers
little achievers low achievers and that
difference is equivalent to one point
six years of school so pretty huge these
are our kids on one of the last days of
camp wearing a youtube t-shirt making
our YouTube logo doing a pretty good job
and I'm still me kid and well first hear
from just one of the students reflecting
on their camp experience they said this
they they taught us how math is for
everybody and I believe that I wasn't a
math person before but now I believe
that anybody can do math and that helped
me a lot the way I thought the math is
all about right answers and wrong but
it's really best ideas and it's very
creative and that helped me like it a
lot more so I chose this because it has
two things in it one was we change the
students beliefs about who they were or
81 of the students on the first day told
the researchers am NOT a math person
this matter they were lower
high-achieving
they could may
the one person in their school or their
class that they thought of as a math
person you wanted to put a hand up
really quickly
so we changed that idea to them we told
them is no such things a math person
everybody can do mathematics and grow
brains and then we also as a student
said we changed after them so they
didn't see it as a subjected right among
answers but one about ideas that's very
creative so we had to watch now a little
film that a filmmaker made and what I
like about this film is so she she
filled that teaching but she also filled
with use school and did it as aa sort of
what happens before and after the camp
that we can watch now some people think
I'm not good at math I can never do
anything and not good at it I'm just
going to give up a lot of people think
of it as like prison like um you don't
have any freedom okay can I go to your
notebook okay three chapter one okay
here's your worksheet but math textbook
is kind of like the Bible you have to
kind of worship the textbook and I don't
really like that everybody's going to
quickly and I thought if I didn't go
quick people think I'm like not smart
[Music]
there's a lot of mistakes and I got I
got it really sad about it
you make mistake they're pretty much
done in
I can't do it fast and they're so smart
because they can and I'm not smart and I
just kind of stopped you feel like
you're serving a sentence for like
nothing I love it I just look like you
believe I've done better with math when
I was talking with people sharing ideas
four or five grains was better than one
I'll see it one way but then someone
else will see it another way and I'll be
like oh my gosh that makes so much sense
I love that we're getting different
answers out because lots of problems in
math there are different answers have
more than one way to solve as in real
life you're not gonna jump in one thing
you're going to do many things you're
going to be to these different methods
[Music]
take your time and just experiment with
every way that could possibly work you
definitely have to be patient
because certain problems they take
forever math isn't about speed and you
can make mistakes and learn from them
math isn't like the enemy and it can't
hurt me
you can run wild you can pass ideas by
each other I thought that max was all
about right actors and all not I believe
that max is really about ideas and
creativity it's a lot more inspiring
[Music]
so I hope you liked watching that film
great to see kids and that is on our
website under videos if you'd like to
show other people that will share it
with others and so some of the different
messages we gave the students in campus
eaves and we know these messages had a
big impact on them we told them the
mistakes and struggle and challenge a
really important for brains their client
in your brains are growing the most we
told them that talking about math is
really important and it has a special
name in mathematics which is called
reasoning that's what makes somebody a
mathematician actually scientists prove
things by finding new cases or cancer
examples that mathematicians prove
things by reasoning by making logical
steps between ideas and we told our
students it is really important to
reason with each other we also tell them
that in mathematics people when they
have sort of ideas of a half-formed
ideas they call them conjectures a bit
like a theory in science and in
mathematics they're called conjectures
and we learn to talk to each other about
different conjectures we had and then we
also told students and this is really
the topic of today but when we visualize
and see mathematics visually and when we
think about numbers those bring up those
involve different parts of the brain
when we think about mathematics as a
second word that's another different
part of the brain and when we think
about those things together when we see
something visually and we think about
the America that causes a brain
connection to happen that's really
important so um we wanted to start the
camp by really being very clear that we
want to see math visually and that is a
really creative subject where we get to
see it in different ways and that partly
came from this research that I'm working
now with in neuroscientists and what
they now know is that when people work
on something mathematically there are
five different
areas of the brain involved and two of
the areas of visual pathways and in fact
the dorsal visual pathway is the main
brain region for representing quantity
so when you improve your mathematics
understanding it's not about just
building up knowledge in one area but
it's about communication between
different areas of the brain when my
sites for students is just always about
numbers that's really strengthening one
part of the brain and not encouraging
those connections that can come out when
it's also visual or about words so these
are the two visual pathways that you see
in this picture and what we want is
connections to happen between these
different mathematical pathways and when
we use numbers but also visuals and
words and algorithms and we communicate
between these different ways of knowing
that that brings about those three
important brain connections that we see
as part of the genius study this was one
study at Stanford where they studied
students between the ages of 8 and 12
and they found that as they got older
and learn more their brain becomes more
interactive and that the connections
develop between skin Golic and visual
representations remembered as a
particularly important connection so
we've written more about this if you'd
like to read about it we have a paper on
our website that's called seeing as
understanding with different ideas and I
often say to teachers it's really good
to make all math visual but some
teachers haven't themselves had
experience at maths as a visual subject
and so that seems difficult I have made
this particular idea of visual I think
the best advice is ask the students
they're really good at coming up with
different visual ways of expressing that
and that's always a great thing to do so
I thought which I want to show you one
of the first activities I did with a
students in camp this is a six-minute
video we're going to watch together and
it could have visual dot card I know
some of you know about cards and because
this is really early early on in camp
parley because I wanted students to see
that master the circuit that people see
in different ways and many different
ways of seeing it
I also wanted them to know that math is
a creative subject and that we value the
different creative ways that people see
mathematics and you'll see in the video
I think some of the connecting between
numbers and visuals that help those
growing connections so I'm going to move
to that video now for you to watch after
the video I'm going to ask you to think
about why was this an important exercise
to students what was important about it
do you think call them we now know that
when you think about numbers as at
looking like numbers like this one
pathway your brain lights up and when
you think about numbers visually like if
I were to draw a picture of a number a
different brain part of a lighter so
when you have different brain pathways
like that it's great you have like
double the impact so we're going to be
doing some connections between visuals
and numbers now so this is what I'm
going to do this is kind of an unusual
activity I'm going to show you up here I
collect my thoughts and I'm going to
show you just a few seconds and the
reason I'm going to hold at this 50
seconds is I don't want you to count the
box so I want you to look at the
collections up and work out how many
doctors are without cancer is everybody
ready
I'm really looking to slow
all right how many got swallow it still
today everybody Kevin
excellent so now what I'd like to know
is how you see the seven dollars and why
don't we start with Michael how did you
see the Michael so like I don't know why
but I shouldn't a song I just started
taking a shower huh because they look
like a typewriter I'm kind of that tie
fighters like the wings have three off
three edges create a 3.5 and in the
middle was our formal so I don't know so
to the ISA point yeah yeah yeah good
yeah so it says and this and Mary
Alice's a scoop so Michael I'm going to
say you store it kind of like that and
if we connected numbers to that we would
probably say this as three plus one
three right
who saw it this money to Michael hi when
I saw a lot of it more like in layers I
like it like it's more of a circle okay
with a diet for middle okay to close
then Q in that to spider apartment -
okay so - yeah - yes and 3:00 p.m. a
diagonal so my anyway yeah so
how much what - yeah - yeah - yes
okay so I'm going to say Maya's was to
two adults in the middle and then break
it up these - yeah right so it won't be
the number of people with us - yeah but
Q plus two one right who thought
differently for that
yes it's color oh I saw it was like a
dice like if you roll a five on a date
uh-huh and that was two extra one on the
beach side okay so his eyes you saw was
like that five on a dice and it's not an
extra guy and then you go to here yeah
right what number to be put with that by
unless - great you thought differently
for that it wouldn't get happy are my
entire excuse 380 okay what's so again
with it - three centons
so I'm going to sleep at me like that
the numbers together that's alright look
at that big four explicitly a diamond
okay
and in places our point what is this
timers he'll want to come out to show me
I forget why I was like minutes ago so
at a big one okay yeah and then so years
year year year that's the first place
over huh and then here's you - here -
here here
there's another one right - diamonds are
you gonna fix it up see members conduct
that what numbers would you have jacket
home what I did in my training school
for me
because you use one already yes but you
guys did amazingly well
how many different ways is being it to
come up with well so oh yeah so what
this is one of the reasons we do this
cuz I want to show you this if you think
of math as a subject whether sort of one
answer one way of getting it when we're
seeing it and actually you can solve any
map poking with ways and people to see
massively so I just showed you a
collection of seven dots and you store
it in 13 different ways so now I would
like you to write down now I'd like to
write down if you would and we hopefully
can look at some of your responses why
do you think this is an important
activity to students to do I'm just
going to pause a little to let you to
think about that and write something
down for us why do you think this is
important so thank you for those who you
wrote down things of what wonderful arts
has been given and I think you can go
back and see those after the webinar I
wanted to add one that I didn't think
would probably come up which is we know
also from brain science with an
important part of the brain for the ans
the approximate number system and it
actually develops from students and it's
being able to approximate numbers from
collections of dots and other
collections of numbers and it said that
that students with a well-developed
Hockman and system that predicts their
max achievement for a long time ahead so
giving teams the opportunity to divert
that so that the brain where they were
able to approximate is just inherently
values valuable as well as all the
lovely things people are writing about
that value in their different ways of
seeing and pathways and so on and to me
I often take my students and we do math
the other at Stanford but one of the
most beautiful aspects of mathematics
for me is the multiple different ideas
people have the way they see it
differently
and a different path
that can be taken for every problem that
is just a lovely thing to celebrate and
whenever my students just come up with a
different representation or a different
way of showing something mathematically
I always talk about that Matt you know
that's really such a nice thing about
mathematics but many students don't get
to appreciate going through school
unfortunately oh this is just a picture
I thought you'd like to see if when we
did that dot card with a group of
teachers in Canada and you can see their
many different representations some
different ones that they came up with
the room came up with I don't remember
like 30 different ways of seeing it so a
couple of other things I want to share
with you before we finish for questions
and that is I've recently come to this
scientist who's really interesting in
the name is Robert Bjork and he talks
about how when you learn something new
your brain kind of will relates it to
what you already know it's very clever
about the way it connects things
together and you also talked about how
when you retrieve something and when you
talk about something when somebody's
asking you a question and you have to
think back in your mind and retrieve it
that itself is an active learning and
ask you retrieve something that
knowledge in your brain becomes more
retrievable in the future so it's really
an example of how important it is to
have students our students questions so
they have a active retrieval and he
talks as well again on this brain
connection piece about the importance of
varying examples and situations so how
do you encourage these brain connections
and growth we can probably all agree
that a lecture ticking isn't Elector
some people can be making some
connections where the opportunities are
pretty minimal to make those really
important brain connections
project-based learning has lots of
opportunities for that words to design
and collaborate and connect but so many
people at the hard a shift to go to
entirely the project-based learning and
what I wanted to highlight there are
many things you can do in between so I
just show you a couple of them but you
know not lecturing all the time and
maybe not completely project-based but
it's more interactive more opportunities
for connections and I wanted to go back
to what Bjork said that retrieving
information is an active learning so
some people might think well when we
give students pet
and that is an active retrieval but
actually it doesn't help students as
much when it's through a test as when
it's in a learning situation and the act
of performing can actually reduce that
and John Hathi is an Australian
researcher who looked at the sex sizes
and I thought this was really
interesting where they look at how you
did this how much impact does that have
on achievement and I thought these two
were interesting differences teachers
who encouraged students on tests the
impact of that is so low and weak it's
not in in the desirable range but
engaging people in class and discussions
has very high impact on achievement and
that's a great way to get this retrieval
going asking questions having people
talk to each other some cool things
going on at Stanford around this Carl
Lyman is a Nobel Prize winning physicist
and he wanted to he himself if he hardly
learned anything from listening to
someone and so wanted to look at how can
you make people people's learning more
active even in a big lecture theater and
what they're doing now at Stanford he
taught the whole physics department here
which is instead of the lecturer talking
about things so lecture now asks a
question of the students and they talk
about it together in groups and then
they vote on an answer together on an
electric sort of voting system and then
the lecture professor is able to look at
the students answer before giving us a
mini lecture on the ideas and when they
try that in physics in university the
Achieva is twice as high the people who
are asked those questions that they
discuss and when they were just
listening so I we can all do this with
math we can all take ideas and open them
up and think about why how do those
methods work how are they connected to
others can you represent an idea in a
different way as a picture as a cartoon
even a doodle however you're
representing and I do it differently
will cause those brain connections there
are a few examples and then I think I'll
stop the questions that last back to a
perfect example the worst thing we can
do with them is blindly memorize them
and wear it
an act of memorization instead we can
have students engage with the numbers
visually and with numbers and activity
on our website how close to 100 is a
perfect example of that
algebra if you haven't seen me I know
many of you have probably showing
algebra visually I have two TED talks
when TEDx talks when I do that so you
can look at that any algebra example you
can make visual in really cool ways even
things like this conversion of Celsius
to Fahrenheit is usually given as rules
the students do this to the number to
get this number and they practice even
that we completely transform by showing
it as a visual pattern and asking
students different kinds of questions
and all of these questions you see here
engaging with square roots or Pythagoras
or you know can be engaged with visually
when we think that different ways to
visually represent those ideas and it
gives you different opportunities and
helps with those brain connections I
like this example for my friend Cathy
Humphreys instead of asking students
calculate one divided by 2/3 which is a
calculation in one part of the brain
she totally opens up that question by
saying to the student you may know a
rule for working this out don't care
about the rule today what I wanted you
to be able to make sense of this answer
and show your thinking visually and in a
book I have the Kathy does a video of
the students carry out these different
visual solutions and it really shifts
the understanding of different students
so any mathematics at all can be made
visual I challenge anybody to show me an
area of math that can't be visual and as
I said ask the students to think of
visuals if you don't no way then my
colleague Kathy Humphries is often
showing the really cool way of making
this diamond paper where you fold paper
up and once we see teachers using this
now where they ask a question but then
the question like 1/2 third for example
has different requests like can you
solve it numerically can you solve it
visually can you write a story about it
I had an interaction actually with my
and daughter's teacher and she was in
fourth grade that I thought you find
interesting
where she was at a school where they had
I don't think too much ever a good idea
but they had much better homeworks where
they did couples and kink ends but
occasionally she'd come home if I can
lift the 40 questions or 20 questions
and parents know that there was a kind
of that times were kids spirits think
when they're at home in the evening and
they have lots of questions to go
through and what I actually wrote a
little note to the teacher I don't
normally do this with my children's
teachers you're probably thinking
parallel Paul it would be if I was your
child's teacher but and the she came
home with a list and I think about 40
questions and I saw her just feel
terrible about it and I both notes the
teacher where I said you know I asked my
daughters to do the first few of these
but then I asked them not to finish the
worksheet because I didn't want to think
this is what math is so um it was good
we had a good conversation but what the
teachers changed and I love this totally
amazing
it was very giving 40 questions now she
has four questions and that she asked
the students can you buy the story about
this can you draw a picture can you do
the calculation as well but can you also
do these those things and you can see a
little example in the diamond paper
there and that's amazing that that is
what will get those different
connections going and doesn't make kids
feel terrible anything so they actually
feel engaged with Matt so a lot of
people think practice is very important
but it is important practice is what
changes that delicate brain pathway into
a more permanent brain Park away but
what is productive practice is not
repeating the same idea over and over
again it's seeing an idea of different
ways different forms different
representations so um I will skip these
and tell you if you want some lovely
visual creative math lessons every year
we give away a free week it's called our
week to inspirational maps is already
two weeks so ten days but on the website
a new set is coming out of visual
creative math lessons that really gives
you these opportunities and those that
all kind out
teachers taken use of our website and
we're also working on new set of books
and fourth grade books are coming out
this summer where we've taken the whole
grade level and thought about how do we
show this idea to Big Ideas and
visualizing and so those look out for
those and YouTube is doing great and we
now get three million on the site and
are put in our months where we give
things away like our weeks math so
that's amazing
a newsletter is opening over hundred
twenty countries so it's very cool and
so I think I'll stop now and answer some
of the questions that have come in
because I have quite a few and in front
of me and if you want to ask a question
now would be a good time to ask it so
I'm going to start off with the first
question about that actually popped up
during the webinar where somebody said
but surely some people can perform
calculations more quickly and more
easily and I think this person was sort
of challenging the idea that was
nobody's just a math person and it's
true some people can be a calculations
more quickly or more easily but what we
know is that has come about because of
the millions of opportunities have had
for brain flows and the messages have
been given so when you see students to
find out more easily than other students
I don't think what you think about is oh
this cousin of an ass person but this
person has had more opportunities for
that to develop and we can make those
opportunities more equitably available
somebody that's that we're doing a
summer camp in Chicago and we've got
students of ten days and three hours a
day is that enough to develop growth
mindsets and yes definitely we had
students for longer time than that is
true but we recently did a one-day
intervention with students or we brought
girls onto campus and did like a little
mini camp for a day and even that day
the students will tell you really change
the way they thought about math and
themselves so definitely that's enough
time I think EE said how can you
recommend a routine like cards for a
grade three to five I think we
really good to use number talks of
different types everyday so a dot card
is a particular type of number talk
that's visual I love them and we have
them inside our week of inspirational
maths and sherry parrot
Paris is a book of many different cards
um but some of them to be numbers as
well and number talks are also wonderful
and you can find lots of information
number talks and so it's all car to our
number number talk every day is a great
routine for that somebody says I'd love
to access this video the dot card for PD
for aspiring teachers as it's available
so that video is inside the online class
and that's the way that you can get that
so I really recommend for those teachers
that you'd like to learn to met getting
them so to register for classes really
best way to see that so the reason one
does have a quantity of developers do a
pointer which efficiency calculation
processes pathways and such though
should take over so it is true that
after you've really understood something
and after you've engaged with it in
different ways visually and numerically
you may get to a routine where you're
able to very quickly come up with
different ideas or calculation or math
facts for example some people think that
I'm saying math facts aren't important
that's not what I'm saying but I'm
saying we can learn math spectra
visually and deeply and after you've
done that then they are more accessible
to use in in a more efficient way and I
guess that's fine
but what I try and get away from is a
misconception that we do this in the
early years and the younger children so
that later people don't need this and
that isn't the case and people need to
be engaging visually and with numbers
all the time whether they're sixteen or
twenty five some people think oh well
some people are visual people and
they're visual learners and some people
are visual learners that's also a
damaging idea because they've used don't
think visually or your students don't
think visually you need this you're
learning more than anybody to develop
those pathways and it's not okay to just
think all will just work in numbers for
those people we want everybody to be
developing those and using those
pathways through their lives not just in
some years and something that want your
book and how calculators fit into
student problem solving for middle grade
students I don't think the calculate the
question is is never a question of do
you or don't you I mean yes we always
want to use really good technology we
may not have students use calculators
all the time and and we don't want it as
a replacement and number sense number
sense is really important for students
but when they get past and into higher
level mathematics um or in middle school
for example they it may be better to
have a music calculator at some times so
you can get on to other ideas that
you're working with them on so they
don't have to be calculating everything
in that slows everything down and that's
fine yeah you want to development under
sense but I'm having a calculator is a
really good thing it allows you to move
into other content which is great our
sixth to eighth grade uses the mp3
curriculum does this quick and still fit
the bill in my mind so yeah I think the
CMP so economics
wanted a good curriculum that are out
there I don't think any published
curriculum at the moment pays enough
attention has taken it on the brain
science and the I the knowledge we have
with anything visually and creatively so
that's why we're actually working in
their own set of materials now but
definitely that's one of the better ones
to use one of the new curriculum books
released and how can we get them so the
great for book is on Amazon now and the
great size will be the one that follows
it fairly soon afterwards and then
really three and then a moon to middle
school grades and then closest to me but
it will pay to the wire we were little
tiny team at you cubed and
and we really try to make really
high-quality materials for people so I
said how do you keep the spirits in
practice countersued get frustrated
instead of talking about problems in
multiple ways
they started memorizing algorithms it's
the same old way so what that means that
end it means but so I don't think we
ever need to have kids just practice
numerically without visuals without
different ways of thinking about and
different ways of doing it
there's no successful students or the
ones who understand algorithms not just
reproduce them I did a big analysis with
the Pisa team which is really
interesting because data from 13 million
students from across the world for 15
year olds and we were able to analyze
their approach to mathematics some of
the students had ulema eyes their way
and thought memorization was the way to
be successful as many people have in the
u.s. other students are seeing big ideas
and seeing connections what we found by
analyzing this data set was the
memorizers for the lowest achieving
students in the world they were the
lowest achieving students within each
country and every country that had a
high number of memorizers is a low
achieving country the u.s. is one of
those so that we wrote it up in an
article for Scientific American and you
can find that on our website so I see
we're coming up school 11 motoki do you
want to finish something go through
thank you all again for joining us today
with the webinar have a great day